we will begin though with the
coronavirus the new steps being taken to
limit the spread of it across the
country on Friday President Trump
declared a national emergency the move
is expected to free up nearly fifty
billion dollars to combat the pandemic
the announcement stirred Wall Street to
a late day rally overnight the
president's 30-day travel ban on foreign
nationals flying from most of Europe
went into effect here in the US the
virus is sickened more than 2,200 people
killing at least 51 early this morning
another bit of financial help was passed
after the administration reached a deal
with the House on a coronavirus relief
bill Ben Tracy is at the White House
with a very latest on this Ben good
morning
Jeff good morning that bill does call
for free testing for any American that
needs one in the White House says it
it's going to unveil a new website as
soon as tomorrow that will actually
screen for who should be tested but at
this point the president still can't say
when any American who needs a test can
get one I am officially declaring a
national emergency two very big words
after weeks of downplaying the
coronavirus President Trump now says
it's an emergency
freeing up as much as fifty billion
dollars in funds to combat it cutting
regulations on health care providers and
instructing every state to create
emergency operation centers the next
eight weeks are critical we can learn
and we will turn a corner on this virus
some of the doctors say it will wash
through the president touted a plan for
nationwide drive-through coronavirus
testing held in the parking lots of
major retailers such as Walmart but when
asked if he takes any responsibility for
the federal government slow rolled out
of testing kits the president said this
no I don't take responsibility at all
six days a Family Medical Leave
unemployment insurance for the children
late last night the House passed a
sweeping coronavirus relief bill the
result of more than a dozen phone call
negotiations between House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and Treasury Secretary Stephen
minuchin it does not include the payroll
tax cut the president
wanted we had to get this testing bill
passed coronavirus test kids will now be
free but the question remains whether
President Trump will actually get one
after being exposed last weekend at
mar-a-lago - at least one person who is
now tested positive for the virus the
president says he won't self quarantine
are you being selfish by not getting
tested and potentially why did say I
wasn't going to be tested are you going
to be most likely yeah mostly not for
that reason but because I think I will
do it anyway now despite what the
president just said there about most
likely getting tested late last night
the White House released a memo from the
president's doctor that said at this
point he doesn't need a test and that
his interactions with people who are now
infected had been what they're calling
low risk Michelle all right Ben Tracy at
the White House thank you